tubes this has been the most fascinating
conference in a way however sadly for
uncertainty because in terms of where
the economy is going on the worldwide
basis we still have some major unknowns
and I think that when we come to London
with the conference in London the
economic conference in April will be
able hopefully to advance our state of
knowledge the one thing that's important
even in this time of great uncertainty
sent values that every quarter to shop
is maintained that we all go back to our
companies and emphasize the importance
of real moral values in our obligation
to the community at large that's what we
must be out of here let me get to
Mountain View hopefully we'll take our
views only follow me in the end of the
recession further